hello step forward here with a gamespot
news update PlayStation 4 users are
going to be getting their hands on
update 1.7 very soon and it's all in
with share factory and out with copy
protection which is fantastic news for
expert hackers like me PlayStation
Europe has confirmed on Twitter that the
ps4 S long-awaited system update 1.7
will be ferried down internet Pikes and
right into your machine next Wednesday
April thirtieth the update will bring a
new app share factory which allows users
to perform basic edits on their captured
videos and also save them to an external
drive making uploading to YouTube a lot
easier you'll be able to do such
wonderful stuff as add clip and
transition you can even add music and
your own face so people know you made it
an option to turn off hdcp or
high-bandwidth digital content
protection for games will also allow
users to use their own capture devices
such as the Elgato Game Capture HD
allowing you to make videos on such
excellent programs as quantel avid and
Windows Movie Maker the 1.7 update will
also bring with it the option to preload
games purchase digitally off the
PlayStation Store so have you been
yearning for light editing tools on your
console and what's your favorite
transition do let me know in the
comments and also stick around for this
transition outro